you're closer now than ever
Deadpool on blu-ray helps you be ready
anytime ask your doctor if your heart is
healthy enough for Deadpool on blu-ray
if you experience joint pain easy
bruising vomiting or clay colored stool
stop watching Deadpool immediately if
you experience hair loss skin sores and
irritability you may actually be
Deadpool and if you experience an
erection lasting longer than four hours
you're welcome
on blu-ray and DVD
hey youtubers is Charlie so happy
Captain America Civil War days just a
fun blu-ray trailer for Deadpool I'll
explain what the special features are
and I'm doing a special giveaway they've
had a good run of Deadpool erectile
disfunction testicular cancer jokes I
wonder what the go-to jokes are gonna be
for cable and I think they're really
waiting til they cast the cable
character before they start doing
Deadpool 2 promos like this once they do
it's gonna be awesome I'll talk a little
bit about cable at the end of this
because they they have said a few things
about the actor that they're looking for
for the most important stuff they're
releasing with this DVD obviously all
the deleted scenes there was a whole
bunch of stuff they had to leave on the
cutting room floor there were a couple
of extended montages they had to cut way
down like when he starts going after the
bills he starts trying to find Ajax so
he just goes on this killing spree one
at a time in that white costume very
much an easter egg for his x-force
costume but there was another extended
scene where he starts looking for the
cure for cancer so there's a lot of that
then there's a lot of extra riffing
where he's going back and forth with
weasel a lot of jokes like that then you
just had to drop that were a little bit
dirtier they're too big commentary
tracks I'm always a big fan of
commentaries one is with Ryan Reynolds
in the writers the other ones with the
director Tim Miller and Rob Liefeld the
creator of Deadpool in the comics
standard blooper reel applies and then
there's a mystery bonus feature that
says Deadpool is fun sack which does
make you feel like he's going to show
you his ball sack really it's just a
collection of all the weird promos they
made you know normally a movie like this
will just release trailers and teasers
Deadpool got a little creative that's
one of the reasons why it was so awesome
because they probably had the best
marketing campaign of any movie I feel
like civil wars had a little bit fun but
because it's not r-rated you can't have
quite as much fun as you can with a
character like Deadpool cable talk
though I know it sounds like we're gonna
be talking about Comcast or Time Warner
or something like that but they said a
little bit about where they're going
with the casting for cable in the sequel
they said they're looking for someone
who is huge so I don't think they're
gonna be going with Stephen Lang Stephen
Lang was just one of the big actors that
people were pointing to saying you know
he would make an awesome cable and I
totally think he would make an awesome
cable what I think they're gonna end up
doing is casting someone a little bit
younger and just aging them up a little
bit I'm totally okay with them casting
and unknown just as long as he's a good
match for Ryan Reynolds energy he has to
be someone who can hold screen time with
Ryan Reynolds if Deadpool just like
walks over him all the time it's not
gonna work you
to feel like their good pair together
because Fox is skipping San Diego
comic-con they're not bringing any
footage for any of their movies they
might use the weekend to just drop a
teaser the same way the Deadpool test
footage got leaked in 2014 so they might
do a version of that without actually
doing a Hall H presentation which means
that you would still get something
really awesome it's just that you
wouldn't have to camp out in line to see
it if there's any more news about it
I'll totally include it in a video
there's a bunch of New Mutants talk
that's been going on so I'll also post a
link for the New Mutants video that I
did in the comments but what I'm doing
just in honor of the DVD coming out is
I'm giving away a free copy so all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video I know
I'm doing a Captain America Civil War
giveaway too so what's gonna happen is
is I'm gonna be posting my non-spoilery
Captain America Civil War review tonight
then on Friday I'm gonna post my Civil
War Easter Egg video there'll be
spoilers in that I'll announce the
Deadpool DVD winner in that video so
just look out for that in if you're
wondering I think you can still get the
special features if you buy the movie on
iTunes but you probably have to pay
extra I don't know if they're giving you
more for free in related Deadpool news I
actually did it in Avengers infinity war
video the same people that are making
Captain America Civil War are making
infinity war they talked a little bit
about what they're doing with that how
they're changing the titles a little so
I had a little bit of fun with Deadpool
vs. Thanos so I'll post a link to that
in the description but as you'd expect
Deadpool gets his hands on the Infinity
Gauntlet and things get crazy if you
guys are seeing the movie tonight
free pass to embarrass your girlfriend
in public cap says it's totally okay so
why you guys wait for my Captain America
video tonight you can click here for
that Avengers Deadpool spider-man
infinity war video and you can click
here for my Deadpool Easter Egg video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you